[Music]
looks like the real Speaker of the House
congresswoman Acacio Cortez his team is
in some hot water tonight following the
sudden departure of her chief of staff
joining us now from a West Coast
newsroom with the latest is on the
breaking news our chief News
correspondent out there Trace caliber
pilot he was the guy that said oh the
green new deal in the beginning had
nothing to do with climate change that
was the guy
tell us about his problems tonight and
he's working on the green yeah he's
working on the green new deal but saqqaq
chocker body was the controversial chief
of staff Sean for Congress member
Alexandria Castillo Cortez he suddenly
resigned on Friday and now our corporate
cuz in the New York Post is reporting
that Chakrabarti is being investigated
by federal officials for fundraising
violations the Federal Election
Commission says complaints only lead to
investigations if there is enough
evidence to back them up in this case
the issue is to political action
committees or PACs that Chakrabarti
started to support progressive
candidates the allegation is that more
than a million dollars was funneled from
the political action committees into two
private companies that are controlled by
Chakrabarti of course PACs are subject
to very tight rules on spending and
fundraising that private companies are
not subject to Alexandria Acacio Cortez
denies there was any wrongdoing and says
this is nothing more than quote
conservative interest groups just filing
bogus proposals ao C's Office says
chakrabarti resigned as chief of staff
to help a non-profit work on the green
New Deal genre trace Gallagher thank you